foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 7450
containment class esoteric
secondary class Mega dope disruption
class Amita
and risk class critical
special containment procedures
scp-7450 is uncontained the SCP
Foundation in its current iteration no
longer possesses the resources or
Personnel required to contain a CP 7450
it is unlikely that any third-party para
natural classification and containment
organizations would if they indeed still
exist be capable of containing scp-7450
due to the critical threat that scp-7450
poses to sentient life forms all
Foundation Personnel are subject to the
requirements of the Magog protocol the
full requirements can be found on the
Central Foundation data server the
primary tenants are as follows
number one
under no circumstances are any Personnel
permitted to leave the confines of their
local foundation's site during a
transience of scp-7450 number two
under no circumstances are any Personnel
permitted to travel to an area that will
be in the path of an scp-7450 transients
within 72 hours
number three
under no circumstances are any Personnel
permitted to look at or listen to
scp-7450
by order of the foundation OverWatch
administrator any Personnel found to
have purposely or unintentionally
violated one of these requirements is
subject to summary execution by any
other member of the SCP Foundation
adherence to these requirements is
Paramount to the successful continuance
of the human species
as a result of the foundation's
inability to contain scp-7450 and the
resultant circumstances that arose
following its Ascension the SCP
Foundation classification committee has
ruled three to zero to update
scp-7450's containment designation from
the apollian class to the megado class
to distinguish between entities or
anomalies that will inevitably result in
the end of the world and those that
already have
description
scp-7450 is the group designation for
four massive humanoid eigen weapons that
ascended to godhood on the 13th of
December 2028 the Ascension of scp-7450
was predicated by the arrival of the
celestial 981 Ajax entity on October 14
2025 the end product of the interaction
between 981 Ajax and scp-7450 was the
utter annihilation of 981 Ajax and
immediately following that the rapid
escalation of an XK Class end of the
world event caused by the Cognito
hazardous and catastrophic ontokinetic
effects of
scp-7450's presence on Earth
scp-7450 entities range between 18.9
kilometers and 23.5 kilometers in height
they are humanoid in appearance with six
large avian Wings emerging from their
upper and lower back
scp-7450 entities have a single arm and
hand on their right side in which they
carry a short curved sickle the entities
have humanoid legs which terminate at
the ankles and are seemingly incapable
of locomotion instead moving by way of
levitation though the legs do move as if
ambulating surviving descriptions of
scp-7450 indicate other possible animal
characteristics such as claws feathers
on the arm and legs Serpentine Tails Etc
they are named in descending order of
size Palace Judith Rachel and arginine
accurate depictions of their facial
features are infeasible to gather it is
currently impossible to obscure images
of the entity's faces to a sufficient
degree to allow for visual assessment
while also negating their Cognito
hazardous properties similarly audio
recordings of scp-7450s vocalizations
cannot be reviewed by sentient observers
both human and sentient AI listeners are
subject to the Cognito hazards present
in
scp-7450s voice
since the moment of their Ascension each
of the four instances of scp-7450 have
been in constant circumnavigatory
transients of the planet each of the
four moves at slightly different speeds
Rachel is the fastest and transits the
globe once every 416 days whereas the
slowest Palace completes the passage in
468 days
sentient creatures exposed to the Visage
or voice of any instance of scp-7450
will immediately become compelled to
follow it in its Transit of the planet
once an individual has been affected
they are unrecoverable subjects who fall
under the effect of
scp-7450's compulsion will make every
possible effort to avoid anything that
would impede their ability to join in
the mass following of scp-7450 and
cannot be deterred short of total
Destruction of their body affected
persons undergo changes over time to
their physiology they cease to age their
bodies become more resistant to damage
and Decay and their features slowly
begin to resemble the scp-7450 instance
they follow they will walk behind their
instance of scp-7450 until their feet
wear down to their ankles at which point
they will begin levitating alongside
other similar subjects lastly these
subjects mimic the vocalizations of
scp-7450 and while exposure to these
vocalizations by non-affected persons
does not have the same immediate
compulsory effect as scp-7450 they will
nonetheless experience the same end
condition after a short period of time
addendum 7450 1. Foundation overseers
address 11 2 2025.
notice from the office of the SCP
Foundation overseer Council regarding
the celestial entity appearing over the
South's eye on October 14 2025.
dated November 2nd 2025
good evening
my name is Armand kachatri an overseer
of the SCT Foundation
we are an organization that seeks to
categorize and contain anomalous
entities and phenomena in our world
we have operated in secrecy for the last
200 years maintaining our world status
quo
as of the night of the 14th we are no
longer able to maintain that Veil
The Entity that appeared over the
southern sky and entity we have
identified as 981 Ajax is a hostile
extra planar entity currently
intersecting with our reality
the disaster ongoing in Johannesburg is
evident of this entity's catastrophic
potential
there have been many questions about the
tragic footage that has made the global
news these last few weeks and the person
hanging in the sky now over the city we
come out speak with full certainty of
their fate but they are in our hearts
at this time we are urging calm and
caution
we understand you're afraid
rest assured we are currently
cooperating with World governments and
other organizations like our own to
determine the best path forward
we have technology that is not available
to the rest of mankind and capabilities
beyond what is commonly accepted as
feasible
we will as we always have stand as the
stalwart Shield between our world
and the unknown
thank you
Armin kachadrian 051
addendum
7452 Foundation overseers address 1211
Jax
they did December 11 2028
over these past three years myself and
my predecessors have made every attempt
to be as transparent as possible with
you about our efforts to defend mankind
against the ongoing threat of Ajax
today I will do the same
this will be our final communication
we have expended every possibility and
all of our resources we have broken up
our containment cells and released every
possible horror into the world in hopes
of balancing the threat of Ajax
we have failed
Ajax will soon open its final eye
and we will not be able to delay it in
truce we never have
take this time to be with your families
we have preparations in place that will
God willing ensure the hopeful survival
of our species
these preparations are buried deep
within the Earth and may survive the
eyes of Ajax
please pray for their survival these
last four mothers of humanity
someday they and their children might
awaken and walk again on an Earth free
from this nightmare
I wish you all peace
good night
Rhys Olson R51
addendum 7450 3 personal journal entries
5 14 2032.
personal Journal
it's in past oversight 43. I finally got
into site Ai and got the same stream of
nonsense as the others it's not Cognito
hazardous itself thankfully
a good canary to see if the place is
worth visiting
didn't sleep well again I've got
Henderson locked up in the cell the
floor below me but sometimes he just
starts howling I need to go change out
the gag I had on him I suspect he's
chewed through it
another letter in today from Sophia
blessings are few and far between but
they're still blessings says she's down
to just 23 but they're still working 23.
I haven't had 23 in two years
she's worried about us I didn't tell her
about Anderson but I told her it's still
too dangerous to come over here Rachel
is Crossing in three weeks and we might
catch Judith as he straightens back out
there are still some stragglers up there
too ones who haven't caught up with the
floaters maybe in a few months
we'll see
antagonizing though it's been a long few
months I thought at first having
Henderson's voice would be enough to
keep me sane but since I snipped him he
doesn't sound much like a person anyway
and even then he's not saying anything
that would be a comfort just shrieking
and gnashing his teeth
seeing another person would be nice
6-3 2032
tight this week
Rachel's passing right now the last week
Henderson has been frothing at the mouth
probably because she's the one who
turned him
I scoped him out a week before last just
to make sure he was still good and tied
up in there
cell was a mess he got out of his straps
at some point and started scratching at
the walls he made decent progress and he
turned his hands into stumps maybe he
thinks he'll be floating around on his
wrists
sound cancellation is still holding up
when we lost sight eight they were about
16 meters down lower than us and Palace
still got all of them that was a close
call I was on the phone with Harold
Bates and he just starts crying
I threw it across the room and stayed
out of there for a week when I came back
the phone was still on
total silence at the other end
but all this time buried down here has
given me time to work I found another
one of the training satellites we used
to use it won't give us much coverage
it's only got two working cameras but we
might be able to get eyes on our China
haven't seen her since she passed Tokyo
last year and went into the ocean
pewter keeps reminding me to check my
update request last time there were
eight sites reporting back I know there
are probably more than that but even
thinking about opening that file makes
me feel clammy
need to think about more productive
things
help I'll check the update requests
tomorrow
6-4 2032
Rachel is taking her time
7 29 2032
I don't think there's anything left to
learn from him and he was a nice enough
guy he's got a lot of walking to do
until he catches up with one of them but
he seemed happier
writhing and screaming but in a more
pleasant way
first time I've been outside in a while
it was really nice out someone was
shining and it's starting to warm back
up again
this guy was mostly clear if I had to
guess most of whatever was left of Ajax
has his Atmosphere by now might be some
left up there but I didn't see any
after I came back inside I just sat
around a little I've been trying to keep
busy but I I don't feel like it today
haven't heard from Sophia in a while
thank God for alto still sending me his
daily updates a picture of his face once
a day every day
not exciting but it's something
nine two twenty thirty two
personal Journal 9-2 2032
still nothing from Sophia
12 14 2032.
personal Journal
8 to 12 14 20 32.
four year anniversary nobody responding
to update requests anymore we must be
getting near the close
I went back and read the rest of this
file
hilariously abridged we had such high
hopes in the beginning and then nothing
planning committees and emails of
encouragement we made it out better than
most that first day they started crying
out we couldn't hear it from so deep on
their ground
64 sites
forty seven thousand personnel
wanted to take us so long to learn how
to stay alive
who are paying a price for Ajax Ajax
what's the point of the secrecy now
what's the point of the updates and
status reports
who's left to read this
I'll tell you what happened if you're
reading this then you're whoever is left
in me there aren't many of us now if any
at all
maybe it'll be Alto
in 1996 We buried four girls at four
different deep well sites
a preparation for the end of the world
they had a close call with 239
sure they had a contingency plan this is
before we found two thousand so it
became moot after that point the project
was more or less scrapped but they
didn't dig those girls up I wonder
sometimes if there was ever a meeting
about it or if they just forgot they
were there
anyway they were buried under a mountain
of sorcery and technology and given
wombs that would operate for a thousand
years for three decades they were down
there until Ajax showed up and turned
2000 into a smoking rack
suddenly we need another option and look
at that Kane finds those four girls and
starts the machines up again and we have
our power shoot again
but then Armond tells the entire world
about them as he's letting everyone know
that we're going to die all our best
late plans all our world religions
suddenly only one thing mattered mankind
had seen us calling real nightmares up
from the bowels of the Earth
as they had never dreamed of and
suddenly we're telling them that it's
all over except
wait
there are these four girls who can save
us what did we think was going to happen
had we really not learned about what
belief does
so they woke up and that was it eight
billion humans crying out for a God to
save them eight billion humans screaming
crying
begging
our city walls fallen and our Idols
smashed against the ground
Ajax I don't even remember what Ajax
looked like to be honest preparing to
open his last eye and people were afraid
we lamented our shared fate
and our Gods woke up
but they weren't built to the Divine
they didn't know what was going to
happen to them the foundation found them
on a street corner somewhere cleaned
them up put 10 billion dollars of tech
into them and then sent them to bed
when they woke up they were gods
they were 13 years old
eight hours we had eight hours although
eight hours to plan before Payless
cracked open her mouth and began
screaming were they scared too were they
afraid of what they'd become their first
action was a reaction I'm sure of it
Ajax came at them and they scattered it
across the atmosphere
their next action Was Fear Gods need
worship and worshipers
it didn't take long they blew through
our Cognito Hazard defenses in seconds
like rice paper before a blow torch
and now it's been four years
half of us we lost to the sisters
another third to exhaustion
tired scared defeated they would put
down their work walk out the door and
then wait for a sister to come calling
I don't know what the point of this was
I don't know what we accomplished here
did we succeed in our mission did we
plan enough do we still have work to do
did we ensure the survival of our
species
I don't know
I'm tired too
we wept when skies opened up and Ajax
opened its first eye and all the eyes
afterwards
we lamented our Grim Misfortune and
prayed for an end to our suffering
why haven't I gotten the message yet
there's there's nobody left to lament
but me
[Music]
9-1 2035
personal Journal 891 2035
I hope it was easy for you Sophia
I hope you found something like a new
life out there
I won't be far behind
419 2036
20 36.
My last journal entry
out of food and the water doesn't work
anymore
Bayless is getting close but I can't
wait any longer
I'll die down here if I don't leave
I can make it to site 89 and then decide
104.
they'll have resources I can use and
maybe research I overlooked
if Payless catches me then that's the
ball game
I'm not willing to give up yet but I
can't wager the survival of our species
against goggles that might slip or ear
plugs that don't work the way they
should
a cloud burning out my eardrums would be
the hard part but with the benefit of
hindsight I should have foreseen how bad
it would be to take my own eyes out
hindsight
a dark joke
I never truly appreciated the dark until
now
spent too much time on this dumb
together
I don't care if it takes a life-loving
and darkness
I'll I'll figure this out
and if you ever get around to reading
this Alto
you can kindly go yourself
two years you had my heart leaping this
is
no time to cry
well wish me luck
Troy
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
James Saba
braided Peach
that loser
Richard broadhurst
fire of prime
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you